compare
98 989
and 98 899.
so we want to compare these two numbers
and to do that let's first think about
what these digits mean what do these
numbers actually mean looking first at
our number on the left we have a 9 all
the way to the right or in the ones
place value which it means just that it
means 9
ones
beside that
we have an eight in the tens place value
so that's eight tens or
eighty
this number these two right here
eighty-nine is the same as an eighty
plus a nine
beside the 8 we have a 9 in the hundreds
place value
so again we can look at that
989
is the same as a 900 plus an 80 plus a
9.
and let's keep going and fill in these
last two we have an eight in the
thousands place
and finally a nine in the ten thousands
place which means nine ten thousands or
ninety thousand
so ninety 98
989 is the same as 90 000 plus 8 000
plus 900 plus 80 plus 9.
which of these place values now seems
like the most important one if we're
deciding how big a number is
which one of these has the biggest
impact on the size of our number
and the answer is the one all the way to
the left whatever place value is
farthest to the left is the greatest
place value
so it is the most important in deciding
how big or small a number is
so when we compare these numbers we're
going to can start by comparing the
largest place value that either of them
has
in this case
ten thousands
is the largest place value both of them
has
and in both cases it's a nine so both of
these numbers
start with ninety thousand
which is equal we can't tell yet which
one is greater so we're going to move to
the next biggest place value
the next largest place value is the
thousands
and again we can see in both cases
we have an eight or eight thousand
so looking at what we've compared so far
these numbers are identical neither is
larger than the other
so we're going to keep going and again
we're going to pick the next largest
place value
which is the hundreds
and our first number on the left we have
nine hundreds nine hundreds but on the
right we have
eight hundreds
so eight hundreds is less than nine
hundreds so this number on the right is
less
than our first number the number on the
left
or we could say that 900 is greater than
800
so the number on the left is greater
and this is our greater than symbol
because we want the open side to be
facing the larger number we want the
open side facing the larger number
so we'd read this as 98
989
is greater
than 98 899
and you might be thinking but wait we
didn't look at the tens and look at the
tens here we have eight tens but on the
right we have nine tens
well nine tens is definitely greater
than eight tens but it doesn't make up
for having less hundreds
hundreds are far bigger ten times bigger
than tens so they mattered more they had
a bigger impact on which of these
numbers was larger
so
we compare
until we find the greatest place value
that's different
and then whichever of those has a
greater number in that place value is
the greater number
let's try one more
so here we're comparing 53
and 350 000. at a quick glance you might
be thinking okay
first number five first number three the
highest place value is bigger here it's
a five
but that's not quite enough we still
have to be sure we're comparing the same
place values
this largest place value here this five
is in the ten thousands place
but the largest place value over here
the three is in the hundred thousands
place
so we're actually comparing 300 000
to 50 000
those are two different place values
we want to compare hundreds thousands to
hundred thousand so looking over here
how many hundred thousands did this
number have
and the answer is a great big zero it
has zero hundred thousands so we can say
zero hundred thousands
and when we compare that to 300 000
that's far less no hundred thousands is
much less than three hundred thousands
so actually this second number is larger
so be careful not just to compare the
first number
but the largest place value
and if there's no digit in that place
value we can fill in a 0 and then
compare
so to read this we'll say 53 000 is less
less
than 350 000
and this symbol is less than because the
larger side is open to the bigger number
and the bigger number is the second
number
so 53 000 is less than 350 000.